i don't think there's no better life
than a fisherman's life
ain't nothing like getting up before
daylight getting out on the water to see
that sun come up over the horizon we're
gonna get pulled in catfish pots in the
morning anyway yeah
we always together when we go out in
that water most of the time
everybody says they don't have two
brothers could work together many years
we have and still be working together
you give and take
some sundays we don't see each other
but other than that every day
ray and i does our own thing early every
morning
we finish up right nice and we meet at
the shop
i love to see him every morning over
there
it makes a great day
it's gonna happen one day
gonna be one morning we're not gonna be
together yep
if i go first i'll see him later
he's gonna save me a seat
if i go first i'm gonna save him one
right alongside of me
we might be fishing that bear
yeah the lord might give us
catch lots of fish then
that's a real plus to life to know that
you got somebody that is on the same
frequency you are
and
someone you could fight in and
know that
if i need a hand over there all i got to
do is call him he'll come and sing with
him to me
if i didn't have a brother like him i
don't know what i'd do
did
you